les troupes de Wagner ont pris
possession de ce quartier militaire de
Rostov un peu plus tôt les membres de 7
millise privée forte de 25000 hommes
selon son chef
èvegeni Prigogine ce sont déployés dans
toute la ville
militaire de Rosto sur le don il est
7h30 du matin les autres sites
militaires de Rostov sont sous contrôle
y compris l'aérodrome la base militaire
de Rostov est un secteur clé pour
l'armée russe car c'est ici que son
coordonnées toutes les opérations
militaires de la guerre en Ukraine
pregoji n'assure que rien entrave le bon
fonctionnement des soldats russes dès
l'annonce de sa marche vers Moscou
l’état-major s'est mis en alerte et à
multiplier les appels au calme comme ici
sur la première chaîne de télévision ou
par le biais de militaires au gradés
je vous demande de vous arrêter
l'ennemi ne fait qu'attendre justement
que la situation politique intérieure
s'aggrave dans notre pays absolument
il est inacceptable de faire le jeu de
l'ennemi en ces temps difficiles pour le
pays point de départ de cette rébellion
le bombardement supposé de caserne où
était stationnés des paramilitaires de
Wagner en Ukraine pour gagner Prigogine
Moscou a délibérément bombardé ces
troupes pour mieux l'affaiblir le chef
de Wagner ne nomme directement pas
Vladimir Poutine et vise plutôt l'un de
ses vis plutôt l'un de ses principaux
bras droits le ministre de la Défense
Sergi shohugo dans l'un de ses messages
vidéos il remet ouvertement en question
l'intervention militaire russe en
Ukraine utilisée selon lui pour servir
les intérêts d'un petit groupe de ligue
arc